in the calculus playlist we came up with
the rationale for euler's formula
euler's formula and i guess that video
has gotten somewhat famous with me
talking about minds being blown and
people not having emotion but just as a
reminder euler's formula is that e to
the i theta and this just the formula by
itself is pretty amazing but it becomes
especially amazing when you substitute
when you
substitute pi or tau for theta and if
you don't know what tau is there are
videos on that but euler's formula tells
us that e to the i theta there's a very
good rationale for saying that this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to cosine of
theta
plus and i'll just change the colors for
fun plus
i
sine of theta and so one thing i want to
do is explore this a little bit can i
express because of euler's formula can i
now express cosine of theta in terms of
some combination of the other stuff and
can i now express sine of theta in terms
of some other combination of the other
stuff let's think about how we can
isolate a cosine theta if this is e to
the i theta let's see what e to the
let's see what e to the
negative i theta it would be
negative
i theta this would be equal to this
would actually let me do it over here
let me do it over here on the right hand
side so e to the negative i theta
e to the negative i
theta this is the same thing as e to the
i
times negative theta which would be
equal to by euler's formula it would be
equal to cosine
of negative theta plus i sine of
negative theta plus i sine
of negative
negative theta well cosine of negative
theta this is the same thing as cosine
of theta
that's the same thing as cosine of theta
and sine of negative theta is the same
thing as negative sine of theta so this
whole thing simplifies to negative i
sine of theta so we can write e to the
negative i theta
we can write e let me do that pink color
we can write e to the negative i theta
as being equal to cosine of theta
cosine of theta minus i sine of theta
minus
i
sine of theta and now this is something
we have something pretty interesting
going on if we add these two expressions
these two equalities right over here the
left-hand side the left so let's just
add them up the left-hand side we're
going to be left with e to the i theta
e to the i theta plus
plus e to the negative i theta and on
the right hand side these i sine thetas
are going to cancel out with each other
the i sine theta is going to cancel out
and we're going to be left with 2 times
cosine of theta
2
cosine theta and so now it's pretty
straightforward to just isolate the
cosine theta divide both sides by 2.
divide both sides by 2 and we get
something pretty interesting we get that
cosine of theta is equal to this
business e to the i theta plus e to the
negative i theta all of that all of that
over 2. and we could do a similar type
of thing to try to isolate let me
rewrite it over so let me rewrite it
this little discovery we made cosine
of theta can be rewritten as e to the i
theta
plus
e to the negative i theta
all of that over 2. so that's kind of
interesting we can now express cosine of
theta in terms of a bunch of
exponentials right over here let's see
if we can do the same thing for sine of
theta so sine of theta let's imagine e
to the i theta and let's try to do the
other you know there's always these
weird kind of parallels between cosine
and sine so let's just see what happens
if we were to subtract this from that so
let's try doing that if we were to take
e
to the i theta let me just rewrite it
over again e to the i theta is equal to
cosine of theta
plus i sine of theta
plus
i
sine of theta and from that let's
subtract let's subtract e to the
negative
i theta well now we're going to subtract
this so we're going to get negative
cosine theta
negative cosine theta and then we're
subtracting this so plus i sine theta
so plus
i
plus i sine theta
and so we are left with
we are left with when we do the
subtraction
the left hand side we have e to the i
theta
e to the i theta minus e to the negative
i theta minus e to the negative i theta
is equal to this cancels out and we're
left with 2i sine theta 2i
times sine theta if we want to solve for
sine theta we divide both sides by 2i
divide both sides by 2i
and we are going to be left with sine
theta is equal to this business right
over here
so let's do this so sine theta so this
is our other discovery sine theta can be
written as
e to the i theta
minus e to the negative i theta all of
that
all of that over
2 i so there's something interesting
about these structures i can write
cosine of theta as the sum of these two
exponentials that are dealing with
imaginary numbers sine of theta as the
difference of these two exponential
numbers dealing with imaginary numbers
actually over here it's actually the
average of the two functions you're
dividing by 2. here we're dividing by 2i
and if you didn't want if you don't like
that i in the denominator you can
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by i this will become a
negative you'll have the i in the
numerator
but either way you will have the same
expression so this is all all i can say
about this is this is just kind of
interesting it's just kind of a fun
exploration of mathematics but maybe
there's something neat about the
structure of these functions what
happens if we were to take functions
like this but if we were to essentially
get rid of the i's right over here they
seem like there might be some kind of an
analog between cosine of theta and sine
of theta and so let's define those
functions in the next few videos we'll
explore them and see if they really are
analogous in some bizarre strange and
beautiful way to cosine of theta and
sine theta so we're just going to make
new function definitions and they're
just being inspired by these new ways
that we discovered to write cosine of
theta and sine theta and i'm going to
call the first function i'm going to
call it
kosh and it really does come from
hyperbolic cosine
and we'll explore more why we call it
hyperbolic cosine but let's just call it
kosh i'm just experimenting right over
here and we'll just say cosh of let's
say cosh of x
is equal to it's going to be all of this
it's going to be inspired by this but
we're going to get rid of all of the i
so it's going to be e
to the x
plus e to the negative x all of that
over two once again just inspired by
this right over here getting rid of all
of the i's and then let's define another
one hyperbolic sine so i'll call it
cinch
cinch for hyperbolic sine sine i guess
you could also do
of x and i'm just going to get rid of
all the i's i'm just being inspired by
this so e
to the x
minus e to the negative x
all of that
over two and in the next few videos
we're going to start exploring this
we're going to start realizing that
there is this strange bizarre parallel
between these things and trigonometric
for entry and traditional trigonometric
functions now these will show up in some
of your mathematics but it is important
these aren't as core especially in
traditional mathematics as these two
characters are here but it is a fun
exploration